Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to three scary-
GAMES
(Starting off great today.)
This is Raven's Point. Apparently, this is just a "boss demo" for a game that's currently in development and I don't kno-
*Mysterious spooky voice*
Listen carefully, Sarah...
My name's Mark... ;-;
*Mysterious, distorted spooky voice*
There's one in this room.
As soon you turn on the lights, you will cross over and meet it.
(Getting confused Mark?)
It wants to play a game.
It's going hide in the room,
and you must find it.
I don't want to find it...
(Aww, spooked Mark. Oop)
*Mysterious spooky voice*
It has a tell, Sarah.
Follow it's path to where it hides, and you will find it.
Mark: I don't want to find it!
*Mysterious spooky voice*
Then, it's your turn to hide.
It will hunt you down, but do not run away from it.
Wait for it to get close, and listen...
For its laughter.
(Oh no.)
Your mind is the safest place you can hide Sarah.
When you hear its laughter, close your Eyes.
(That sounds bad...like really bad)
And do not open them until it leaves.
So, I'm just supposed to close my eyes, and pretend it's not there? *Voice begins talking*
(I guess.)
*Mysterious spooky voice*
The cycle will repeat, and it will lose strength every time, until the tether breaks. Do not let it win.
I will help you, Sarah.
Could you not call me Sarah? My name is Mark and i-it's just really weird...
Trying to force this... Sarah name upon me and I, not 100% sure-  Eww, I can't read that! Ooh...
Okay journal entry, oh, a journal! All right.
Cool, great. What's happening? By the way?
(Don't giggle, search!)
Goo- Whoa, can I get that? Oh, yay, okay. I'll take that. Oh...
No items. I just picked up a fla- Oh?
Oh No... Oh, I hate this. (me too Mark.) Oh, I hate this. Oh,
I hate this. Uh, okay close my eyes, huh? That's all I gotta do? Well, that's easy. Oh...
Boy, I wish I could look at that. That'd be so great.
(I'd rather not look at it, thank you.)
Picked ap a creepy bunny! Oh!
I Picked up a cre-  that doesn't look like a BUNNY? That doesn't look like a bunny at ALL! What are you?! What is that?!
Oh gawd...
(Put it away!)
That is pretty horrifying, that if I do say so myself. That is just plain old, horrifying. Okay good...
Hey, there's the TV from my van. That's great...
*Radio? Phone?* Where's my sister-*Unintelligible*- GO ON, GO ON GET!
What...?
(Uh...?)
Okay, so is he hiding right now? Am I wasting time to find this thing by just,
Dicking around? Take that small tin can yeah, That'll be good for me. I'm happy about- OOOOoooohhhhh...
I'm sorry? Oh no, that was the light. Oh, that was the thing I was supposed to turn on, I think?
Hello? Oh... OH. OH HI?! He-
(Mark run! Just nope!)
Uh oh...
(Yeah! Uh oh indeed!)
Okay... Just gonna close my eyes...
(Yes, listen to the weird voice.)
Can I hide in here?
(Don't think so?)
No?
(No)
I can't hide in here...
(I thought so)
*Lights kill off*
I'M GONNA CLOSE MY EYES! I'M CLOSING MY EYES!
(Mark don't shit yourself)
I think this is a good idea...?
(Totally)
*Mysterious spooky voice* Wait for the right time, Sarah.
What?
Wait for the right time- *Babbling* Did I die?!
Was that the horrible feeling of death?! It wasn't that bad, I guess. Didn't realize what was going on
I thought that maybe I had done some good.
But apparently, I did something very, very wrong...
{This is where Michale F is gonna have to stop, I hope everyone can continue this well! <3}
(SnowDog's turn!)
Why does the light turn off whenever I pick that up? That's- that's unpleasant.
Okay, so I just gotta wait for the right time then...
So what you're telling me is that I need to let it get close to me until I hear the laughter
And THEN I die. (Makes sense right?)
Oh, shit. Where was that? Hello. Oh, you're in the same place. That's...
That's...that's good.
*Creature moans*
Oh, yeah..
Okay, so I'm...
gonna stand here and just
..just gonna stand right here. I'm not gonna close my eyes.
*Lights flickering*
*Footsteps*
*Markigasp*
*Creature laughs*
*Creature moans*
Mark: OOH!
EEE...
I hated that. I hated that with passion. I hated that very much.
*Creature noises*
No. How long do I close my eyes for?
I'm opening them.
*Whispers*
Okay, we're good.
Why, why, why, why, why? I thought that- I could open my eyes and I thought that I would not be dead
but it turns out-
*Mysterious spooky voice*
You must find it quicker, Sara.
I must find- oh, it was my turn. (Yeah I could tell because of the noises. Do a google Mark!)
Okay. Yeah. It's all making lots of sense. I get it, I'm just a real slow learner. (Oh okay. Me too!)
*Creature noises*
Oh, yeah, there you are. There you are...
*Creature moans*
You little biscuit. Okay, I'm gonna go over here. You know, I'm gonna wait 'cause you're gonna charge me-- (Insert Mark's Editing!)
*Lights flickering*
*Footsteps*
*Creature laughs*
*Creature moans*
Are you gone?
*Creature noises*
Okay, I'm going for it. Where'd you go? You're right there.
*Creature moans*
You make it easy on me. You make it so easy, okay.
*Lights flickering*
*Footsteps yet again*
*Creature laughs*
*Creature moans*
Mark: Oh, I hate that.
I hate that so much.
Can I open them now? Okay.
*Creature noises*
Where? I heard that. Over here?
Hello.
*Creature moans*
Okay, good. Great, I'ma be right here.
I'm hiding.
*Softly* I'm hiding.
*Lights flickering*
*Footsteps*
*Creature laughs*
OAH! Ah, God.
I- I thought- I thought I had that. (You're getting better :D)
I hate this. I hate it! Okay, all right.
*Mysterious spooky voice*
Close your eyes before it reaches you, Sara!
I thought- Am I supposed to wait for the laugh or am I...? Do I just look at it, longingly in its big beautiful eyes? *Chuckleplier*
"Let's play." Hey, that's what I'm doing... (Cool, two peas in a pod.. ;P)
*Creature noises*
Oh, hey. Oh, hi. Hello. Okay. Good. Great. I'm gonna be right...
...here's a good spot. It's good, right here.
*Same thing: Lights flickering then footsteps*
*Creature laughs then moans*
Okay, I don't know if I'm supposed to wait for the laugh but I think that's what I'm supposed to do.
I think, I don't know, man. (YES!)
*Creature noises*
I heard that. Where are you?
Hey, just standing there.
That's good, that's a good thing. Am I supposed to keep this light on? Okay... hi, hi. Hello.
Oh. Oh, God.
NOO! (Too soon, Mark)
TOO SOON!!
Maybe? I don't know!
(SnowDog signing off! Please continue the streak, everyone!)
Let me read these
Okay, so I I do have to wait for the laughter
Okay, the hilariousness of the situation has to strike my soul before I can actually turn off my eyes
I need to see the comedy and lust after it before I can do such a thing as the like has closed my eyes
Good great. I got it's just real narrow timing
Just real narrow
But I got it
Okay, God you shouldn't be squatting over with your back turned
Oh hi, well hi weird place to be oh shit
Close okay sweet quick this time God
Good oh
No, I unleashed the demon
Huh do tell okay
Well
Ain't that some delightful something or other made by Grom bismil games?
okay, so that was um
Interesting, very interesting. I liked it a lot definitely scary
I don't like the idea of anything charging at me and I have to do the timing very closely, but very good
Under under what you may be asking well, I'm going to tell you under
the ocean which means that we're going to be under the
Ocean thing you're adding two and two together now
Well, we just can't decide what year we're gonna randomly
17 a good year. I am very happy with that one. Does this have anything to do with the Titanic?
shit
Another waking up from a dream sequence. Come on. Now how many times have we done this? Oh, I'm drunk
Ooh, there we are
Okay. Well time to rinse my face off with super soap good put my bowl of food on the bed unless that's a bedpan
which means it's
Okay, cool. Hello
Just boo shit
Alright anything back there?
No, but there's a hole in the wall. Okay, I don't know about this. I feel slightly uncomfortable
Under the ship ah
Or that's helpful, I'm sure airflow is real good this far below deck
Yes
Feels good
Locked to the surgeon study, huh? Well, it doesn't bode too. Well that the surgeons on this boat are still studying. I
Guess life is a life of learning
lifelong learning learning this
Okay, who's playing games with me or was that simply the rocking of the motion of the ocean
All right, but if I round that corner and two people are going at it like monkeys in a soap sack
I'm gonna be real upset about that
whose fucking oh
Okay, you know for 1917 this was
All of this tune there gonna be some around this corner Hey, okay nothing
Did I get the keys to the surgeon study? There is no. Oh dear Alice today
We went over the top the joy and serenity of heaven waited us then Alexander condemned
Condemned us all we will wait for him to pay his sins
Face the devil and he will flee from you run from the devil and you are his okay
So what you're telling me is that I shouldn't run away from anything
I see I'm gonna take that quite literally if there's any demons, they'll want to pop out at me
I ain't gonna run away from you. I'm gonna face you right in your stupid
Ran away, but I fought it there's what the feelings hey
Listen, oh
Okay, so it's a whole lot of nothing. Is that what you're saying to me? There's a whole lot of nothing here. Hmm
Mr. Doctor's cow Oh
Was there a mr. Doctor in here hey, I'm gonna go down to the surgeon study and I'm gonna make sure
No doctors are been cowardly
Hey
can I
Hello
That's a good thing why no no
way
Whose flopping around down there. It's a big dick Larry out there
Ocupado I'm bit. You don't need to try the doctors out very cowardly
Yeah, I don't think so if I don't have to I would much rather not
Yeah, I sure you
Okay, you're just gonna keep doing that, huh?
Okay. Well the doctor is out there was no point coming in here. Hey, I'm gonna face the demon. Who's there!?
No one okay, not a hundred percent sure what I'm doing here. Yeah, I hear ya
What am I supposed to do? Oh shit. Oh I can Crouch. Oh
There's something there. How do I- Oh I can boosh it! (weird accent)
No one's here. Ha ha ha
No one's anywhere. Who's knock knocking on the-
chamber door
What? Oh... OH
Yea that's normal
Yes
That's a whole lot of normal. I don't know what's happening here, and I don't know why
But I got a bit of a bad feeling about it... okay?
Stairs you say? Ok. So those are locked. So I need to find another key is what you're saying
*Creepy noises* OOH, IM NOT GONNA RUN FROM YOU.
That's what you get ya I'm not running from nobody I'm gonna face the devil. If that is you Mr. Tall man
Oh good, more lunch.
*Slamming door*
Oh. Yeah, there's good closing doors make sure there's no flooding spreads nowhere. Good great crew meal times
Those are very strict
Inquire at lord of service for service crew times.
Ah
The Lord of service much like the lord of the dance. Hey, was there a point to coming in He-
Oh
Is real dark *burst into laughter*
*Gasp*
O
Our breath reeks of death
*Click* *Click* *Click* (Random Markiplier noises)
Oh
This is wonderful, hey, I like this this is all good stuff
Why does my breath reeked of death? What have you been feeding me? What have I been eating exactly?
*Record player starts up*
Okay, yeah
O-kay... IS THERE SOMETHING BEHIND ME?!
*Sigh of relief* Okay
There was something behind me, I mean there's something in front of me now laughing maniacally off in the distance
But I think that's better than something laughing behind me. Sort posts and signal messages before 8:00 p.m. Greenwich Time
Okay. Handle with care
Okay, all this is super okay
Very confuzzled. I'm not sure where I'm supposed to go
Hi coat, ah
the stripper pole room
Great. Ooh
Hello, I got keys. That's good
Hi, Hey, how are you doing? Hey, what is up!
AH-I- I'm gonna face demon! I'm facing the demon!
the demons gone
Face, the demon. Demon goes bye-bye
It's as simple as that--it is as easy and simple as that now where was the place that I needed this key?
Oh, here we go
Perfect! Up again, exactly where I needed to know I needed to go great
Anything else lurk-
Okay, well nothing grea- oh, I'm gonna face you I'm gonna-
oh, OH WHOA*4 WAIT A MINUTE, WAIT A MINUTE
WAIT A MINUTE, wait a minute. Hello? What happened to you?
OOOOOH
Well, that's curious
Huh?
Something tells me that ain't supposed to happen
Pathfinder's will walk here. Oh, there you are. Okay
OkAyyy?
Oh! I'm up
What?
What? Okay. Yeah a big guy. I'm just gonna go here. All right, here we go. I can't- Oh crawling. Can't crawl can't crawl. You're tall
Ow
Once across the cheek. Owie... so what do I get to do face is demon. How do I do this?
Hi, I'm I run. I'm a run in here. I should be able to crawl through here. I would think I crawled through here before
Ah!
You clobbered me. Okay. What am I gonna do run right through you? I'm gonna do that. Here we go. I'm coming for you
Yeah, don't even think about it, bro.
Ow
I have a funny feeling that I'm supposed to be able to crawl through that little hole there
But it's just not letting me for some reason
Yeah, I think it's supposed to go this way, but it's not for some reason.
I think I might have bugged -.-
Alright, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna leave him here. Hey, come on, come here. Come here
I just want to converse with you. Come here. Yeah, it's ready. Hmm
Yeah, ok. Yeah, come on. Keep coming
Ok, keep coming
No, no, no, no, come all the way down all the way. Whoops. Hey buddy. Hey, you stupid TALL guy
*Random Mark noises*
La-da-de *3. There you go. Come on. Oh, he doesn't want to go down
Ok, well problem is how do I that seems to be a bit of an issue?
Oh, you clobbered my tongue or maybe?
occurred ring around the rosy
pocket full of posy
Ah, he catches me on the backswing. I don't think there's a way around
Cuz I think you're supposed to be able to go in here, but it just don't let you go
Okay, I think I might've bug this one. What if I go around?
Like what if I go down and then all the way around and back up here technically, it's all part of the same
Nah, the doors closed. Well, that sucks. Oh
Fuck oh whoa. Hey
Well that's not nice! the helmet dude, what's with your tude? Hey, buddy. Hey, listen, listen, you need to calm yourself down
Yeah, once he once he swong there's no escaping the swong. His swong is too powerful
Alright, maybe I could in the pole-dancing room if he comes this way. Oh, no it I went wrong
Oh, this is wrong. Hey dinnertime
ding-ding-ding
Come get your grub
Oh, he's gonna meet me right here. He's gonna meet me with his meat hooks. I thought it was that
Oh, here we go whole dancing room. Hey, buddy
Hey, buddy. Hey, buddy. What's going on, buddy? Oh
Shit, buddy. Oh boy, okay
Ring-around-the-rosie gonna do a pole dance for oh, no, don't Club me
I think this is broken
Sad to say I think it's very broken. My apologies to the chef. I'm gonna get in here. Oh
Yeah, you're supposed to go around there, but I think it's booked. Okay, that's sad so sad
so this is
Floors two now if you guys remember a game called
Scp-087 B it is a game about infinite stairs and in these infinite stairs lurk infinite horrors *Headphone Warning*
*ETERNAL SCREAMS OF THE NIGHT*
This game is similar. You either go up or down in this one. There's no exit. You can only die
Apparently somewhere along the line it starts to get real bad and by bad
I don't mean the game is bad
But I mean bad as in Horrors start appearing from every whichaway
To haunt your dreams and I run I can run
I hope there's no punishment for running like a guillotine or a big swinging blade
Descending from the ceiling but punish me for my own carelessness. See the thing about
SCP-087B was that it was very bad to go sprinting into the darkness *Another Headphone Warning*
*Screamy Boi*
And I have a funny feeling that it's just as bad to do it here man
It is really infinite. Ain't it? I'm not sure if there's like gonna be doors or something or
Offshoot hallways or Puzzles. I do notice. I have a health bar and I
Usually entails there some dangers lurking by every corner
Okay, either. I'm crazy or something's gonna happen at some point. There's got to be something right
it's not just a game with absolutely nothing and it's leaves me here to be paranoid about what the hell's lurking behind every
Corner, this is great. It was good
It was good. I feel comfortable about this. Also. It's very toasty in this room at the moment
I haven't sorted out the air conditioning problem yet, but that's besides the point because I'm on floor 14, and I don't know why
Nothing's happening. Is there really nothing I got this like sense of dread that at any moment
Something's gonna pop out behind a corner which is weird cuz there's nothing really saying that's gonna happen
But it just seems like there should have been something by now. Unless I'm doing some horribly wrong
*Contemplates Life*
*3rd Headphone warning*
What the Fuck? Oh hi. Good. Are you kidding me? What?
Wa-why-whoa!
What are you doing? Why is that a thing? why?
Oh,
What? pardon me that just random why is there another number next to the number of the floor that it is?
Is that just because I finally got something to do something and then that's when the real counter starts is that, is that- *4th warning...Imma stop with the warnings*
Wait, where'd who oh hi. Oh, oh hi, um,
Reruns ready? Okay, I guess I got that one. That's fine. Okay weird, uh
Mr. Red eyes. Okay, you need clear eyes
To fix your red dry ey- oop!
Okay. Well if it's the same thing of whoo, hey Dodge, well if it's the same thing over and over again,
I think, I think I can handle that. It just depends on if it's gonna change to something else and
Then I won't know how to deal with that. Okay you zoom? It's good thing. I'm so fast
it looks like I can go real fast if I use the
strafe method which is using the forward and sideways to go
wrap around these corners a little quicker and it seems to be working like the tighter I make this probably the
Quicker, it's gonna end up being. Whoo. Okay, so they're they're not too much of a problem
The surprise element is over about that one. Great great great so far so good. I mean I made it to floor 42
Yes, oh wait no something hit me my HP is down, when did I HP get down
Why because I was cutting it too close to the enemy there.
All right, what's going on and missed me? Okay. Well, I think I won
I'm not sure what winning means in this game
But I think I won... is it just the same thing over and over again? Is that really all we got here? Same thing?
Over and over again. It's the same
What was that. Whoa. Jeez. That was loud. Okay, why was that loud ah it touched me it touched me with his gross body.
Oh Shit. Oh d'oh shit
Okay. Well, that's weird. Okay. I didn't know you're gonna throw more at me man. Well, that's
That's woah hi Oh shooty duty. Okay. Well that's problem
Okay, so your answer to the question is just to throw
throw many much more
Enemies at me throw many much more enemies. All right, cool. Good I can do with that for the love of the meme
Let me get to floor 69. That's all I want is one floor 69, please no
Oooh, wow, you ran very close. I want to get to floor 69 if I don't get to floor 69. I'm gonna be sorely disappointed
Okay around and out, okay good. Come on just four more floors floor 69, please
Please oh, oh you guys didn't even have eyes did they not have eyes or was that crazy about that?
I'm not 100% sure. okay?
YES! FLOOR 69 BABY
Okay, they must have had eyes and I must be crazy, okay, well now I've gotten my goal
So I guess all I ever wanted to accomplish in life has been accomplished. Hey, you're getting just getting louder. Just getting louder My dood
O, Game over. Alright, well that was a bit *Laughs*
That's a bit dumb. Alright, cool. What happens if you go down probably the same thing but whatever. Yeah, nothing's gonna change
It's the same thing. Yea, same thing. Okay, so that was um, that was not so bad, but not great
Yeah, oh, it's not so bad. So I'm gonna play one more game because I'm gonna count those two as just one
Okay. So this one says it is a short meta hoRror game. I don't know what that means
But I gotta do some work apparently la-de-de-de-da-de la-de-da.
Oh!
La-de-de-de-da. Enter Password uh, Dick
password
Okay I don't know my own password.
Um
Ooh!
Uh Okay, Oh, wa-
What, what? Wait what am I what up what am I doing?
Oh!
I can't read that that is Bruh. bruhsfx2 - okay brah
Oooh
Is that Five Night's At Frombies?
Okay, good. Hey a boat
*Video* My name is markiplier and welcome to plug-and-play the reason-
Oh wait. Oh, what the fuck? Wait. Those are my vid-. Wait a minute. Wait a minute
Those are my videos. It's not just playing them off the internet. These are literally
My videos. Well, I don't like that at all that that's no good.
O- Well shit it crashed
Wait, I saw that
Wai- excuse, excuse m-, excu-u-ho-hoose me
Who was in here? Wait a minute what the F- Wait no open her up.
*Click*
Ooh-
-kay, alright bookshelf, okay. Okay. Let's try this again it crashed but okay
Uh, Uh, Uh It- wa- Umm
Uhh
Umm
Um- Mm
Mm-hmm. You see them everywhere now and don't really give it a second thought as it used tracking cookies to track your browsing history and
Personal profile provide suggestions that might appeal to you
You know the way Amazon suggests new books based on what you just read or when you search for something on Google and then start
seeing ask for it everywhere or when you're a
Twenty-something year old girl in a relationship on Facebook and suddenly all your ads for engagement rings and wedding planets
The point is we're all so used to this that we don't really pay attention to it anymore
But lately these targeted ads have been unnerving Leon Point my plastic sheeting in bulk collect
Your chain saws on sale affordable dry lime overnight shipping available. I don't know how they're doing it
I don't know what technology is driving these changes
But somehow it's like the Internet is reading my mind showing me ask for things that it couldn't possibly know
I wanted I swear to God I didn't touch a keyboard
I didn't do a search and I was so careful to keep all my plans and research and ideas offline
How's it doing this? How does it know about the bodies?
Mark mark eh Mark
penis
Bruh bruh bruh bru-ui-uh
Bru-ui-ui-ui-uh
*Mimicks* if you're a Youtuber consider closing this window as soon as possible, or press the pause button twice
Right. So this is all files
You're just gonna get a lot of weird sound effects child goes missing bra. I don't know how to make fake news news
I'm gonna promote my game here the apartment 3 it was a bad game. Alright, you have to play my game
I'll let you play my game if you can complete your work today, you can't refuse
Okay, good. Okay, cool. Um
*Distorted*  GrEAt
I don't know what i'm doing.
Don't know what's going on. I'm taking a tinkle. that's what's going on. I get it now this game makes sense.
I understand this fully and directly. Yeah
There we go. It's just got a shake two shakes no more than that, or you're just playing with yourself
*Creepy Laughter*
Wash my hANds. Wa-wash my hands. Wa-wash my-
Nah you know it's good I don't need to! I don't need to wash my hands.
Oh
That's dork
Nice dork. Where is it? Where is it? Let me lick it. Oh god. I'm never gonna be able to give the lights back on
*click*
Boom ok got it. Okay, so I'm gonna go to
creepypasta.com/intuitive-advertising.
Okay. So this is what we got
Intuitive advertising you see him everywhere. Oh, oh, I know what that is
That's what was just here. Copy and paste the draft from your notepad?
Oh I know what it wants. Oh, I get it Oh
OH! What did I do?
Okay, I broke that
Ooh shit
All right. Ooh What's this?
Oooooh!
That is broken.
Oh Shit.
Oh god
Well, that's what I get for not going to the bathroom when I needed to
Okay
Okay, we're locked in huh?
Okay good
I'll just get some work done. Let me get some work done
Can't ther- there we go. Here we go. Okay
Check your IRL desktop for a folder if there's no folder on your desktop check games directory for a folder name puzzle.  All right
I'll play your game. All right puzzle. Here we go. Okay. All right. So hint what do we got?
The password is in base64 format
You got a decode at Google might help you okay, Hint two if you're dumb and can't Google a 64 decode
Here's the last hint for you. Okay?
Mjq, this ain't the password read the hints and figure it out for yourself. Cool. So I got a go decode
Base64 cool. There we go
Decode. Got the password put this right here and the passwords that. Boom got it
I'm smart brain equals big. There we go. Read me
Move the brain filed of the game's directory and return to the game. Oh, yeah
This is big brain time return to the alright cool. Here we go. Go. Oh
Ooh
I need to get out of here
And how do I do that? I ask I ask? Oh God all my in the back rooms. Oh god
I'm in the back rooms. I'm in the back rooms. What in the what in the tits is this? What is this? Overlapping crap was?
What is this insanity
What the hell I am in the back rooms. This is the these are the the back rooms
These are the back-ist of back rooms. I've never been more back in more room. Oh hi pup
How are you doing there pub?
Good to see you *3 anyway you guarding this. Good good. Okay, that's locked. Okay, good. Great. What is happening Oh
Reality is intersecting in a million ways. That's not this exit. That's some other exit. That's not what I'm.
Oh god I've lost. Okay. There we go
Cafeteria. O-
-kay, well can't go in there. That's that don't work and that's a dead end. I think
I'm pretty sure it's hard to tell anymore
What's real and what is not real? Oh, wait. Is that my-? Is that what I did but on a doll?
That's what that is daddy you were a problem the whole time
Okay.
Well I-am fine? Oh hi. Hello
*Punch*
Ow *Bursts into laughter*
Okay, I guess I gotta get out of here then. all right cool good, I'm gonna get out of here then. all right good
okay, so you're stalking behind me and
I don't like that.
All right, cool
Shooty-Toody. There was aha. Okay. So let me go up-y the stairs-y because I have a funn-
I have a funkalicious feeling that that actually is part of the way to go. Okay, good. Here's good. I can't see shit
There we go. Okay. Good. I'm in this place. Now, wherever that thing is going. It just saw the exit
Okay, so there's an open door the oh shit, okay
Oh
Where's it going? It's going up some stairs, but that's not where I am
That is somewhere else. It would just went up those stairs. Which means that's the exit
But I don't know if I can actually go out the exit. I need find a- oh ofcourse
I need to find a key for the door.
I don't like that at all. Is it going down the stairs? It's going down the stairs. Okay, so it's going down those stairs
So I got to find a key where the Frick is a key gonna be? I don't even know what the Key is gonna look like
Okay, so it's about to go by that door there
If I'm right about this, yep, there she is. Okay. So what are you guarding in there?
There's something in there that I need to know about O-
there is a hammer
I don't know what to do with a hammer. It's not exactly a key, but it could be a key. Maybe this is the key
Hey, Pup How you doing? Alright, so now it's going through those offices and ah its in there okay. It's right there
It's going in there. Oh whoa. Whoa. Why did you see me? *Mark Mocks*
Maybe this Hammers gonna pry off the doOr or the things?
Okay, well I removed the planks that's part of the problem, where's the key
So another issue I have is if I go up here, I am gonna be stuck if it comes back up here again
so if I come up here, I better find a key
And Fast, okay, so it is a dead end here
There's no key on the ground
There's nothing over here. So this is just a dead end. There's nothing up here. So there's no point in even being up here
Oh, so warm in here. So warm. Oh god you say short. you said this was a short game
This is just a big old pain in the dick. Oh, how long are you gonna be going through that? Okay, fine screw it
I'm gonna look in the I don't think it's in here. It's not in here. So maybe there's a key somewhere around in here
I don't know if it's gonna be like on a desk or something. Okay, it's finally going back up the stairs
I can't see anything. Okay, so it just went back up the stairs. That's good to know
Oh, yeah, there you are. All right cool. Good. Hey, how you doing?
So I'm willing to bet that it's in like the first area. Look I can't find anything. Oh, I'm roasting alive
So it's gonna go out the other side door is gonna make its way down to the exit
It's just a long long patrol path
It's a really long patrol path, and I don't know what I'm looking for.
Oh Shit okay. That was duh. I didn't think you were gonna be coming this way. So
Don't kill me. I have no idea what to do about this. I think that
The the key is definitely somewhere it might be up there still. I don't know
It's just it's a very peculiar system. But you know, it's just like there's nothing I can do
Man, it's just very slow
It's an interesting concept, but it's also very annoying is the main problem that I have with it
It's we won't even let me get it
Okay, so I'm just gonna bail out of that one cuz it hurts my eyes after a while
So it's like it's not a bad concept. I like the meta style of things. I really do
I like that idea for horror games
But in this one the execution is just a little bit flaud because it's too sloped too clunky and not fun
See, it's not even scary. Like I like the concepts of the back rooms. I don't think it's like the best creepypasta ever
I don't know why it's caught on so hard as it has but at the same time
Like I don't think it's like a back rooms thing but the style is there
It's got some potential but it also has a lot of flaws that are drawing it back
So anyway, that'll do for this episode of three scary games
Thank you everybody so much for watching. If you've got more scary games that you want me to play
Let me know down comes below
thanks again and check out more scary games that I've got down in the description or over there in the
Suggestion feed it and as always I'll see you
In the next video
Bye-Bye